another spirit of discussion that plenty
are having is what happens with le'veon
bell john clayton formerly of espn has
suggested that if there's a suitor
it's possible the jets would trade him
before this season even begins i saw
rich simini of espn suggest that he
could be one and done chris i look at it
this way
if
if there would be a team out there that
would say hey we'll take him for five
years 40.5 million which is what it
would be now that the jets have paid him
12. if the jets are willing to pay the
guy 12 million to never play for them
and get whatever they can in return i
could see that maybe a team would be
interested but how can you justify at a
time when you are mired in dysfunction
the idea that you paid the guy 12
million and never actually used it yeah
no i think that's really it you can't
justify that how you gonna sell that to
your fan base i mean you're talking
about you know we just started started
the segment talking about the
dysfunction of the new york jets and
it's a it's a premier media market but
not necessarily a premier franchise oh
and now they're going to trade away some
guy that they overpaid for in free
agency and taking a lot of flack so
again uh yes okay
would they maybe trade le'veon bell away
if the situation is exactly right and
yeah the jets are going to be on the
hook for some of the money and they were
gonna get the right price tag sure okay
maybe but i just don't see that
happening i think that's far-fetched
first of all i don't think there's gonna
be a market uh for a le'veon bell unless
some of the financial burden is taken
away there and but they already took 12
million that's the thing you you could
get him for five years
40.5 million that's 8.1 million a year
that's in the range the 49ers would have
paid but now they can't because they've
got kevin coleman and and jared mckinnon
and five other guys at tailback but five
years 40.5 isn't bad oh you know what i
i thought of an idea look here's the way
you would justify if you're the jets if
you could get a second round pick for
le'veon bell you could basically say we
paid 12 million dollars for a second
round pick what did the browns do two
years ago when they traded for brock
osweiler yeah they paid 16 million
dollars for a second round pick this is
one of those high-end analytics there's
a price tag that you can put right on a
second-round pick and hey 12 million is
4 million less than 16 million so we're
ahead of the game i mean there is a way
to do it if adam gase is hell bent on
getting this guy out i don't think adam
gase is but if he is hell bent on
getting this guy out and you could find
somebody to take five years 40.5 it
really wouldn't be that impossible to
pull off no you're right from that
standpoint right there it would not be
that impossible to pull off and i'm sure
somebody might like his services for
that price tag because yeah that's very
affordable for one of the better running
backs in football certainly a top five
running back in football but at the end
of the day too i mean hey yeah i know
the jets overpaid le'veon bell i get
that but damn le'veon bell still you
know right here just looking at the
paper and looking at the roster he's the
most talented proven commodity on the
jets offense and if you want to get the
sam darnold era going and the adam gets
era going i mean to me le'veon bell yeah
maybe being overpaid is still incredibly
talented has incredibly different skill
set than most running backs in the nfl
and i think he can help that offense out
in a lot of different ways and make life
easier for gays and adam uh for darnold
and everybody else so to me i just yeah
i mean okay maybe they would trade him
if it was all you know perfect but i
just don't see that happening and man
would they be opening up a can of worms
here in new york
and as to the idea that he would be one
and done i'll look at it this way he's
got 13 million fully guaranteed next
year um if he plays well enough that
someone would want to take on that
contract that means he's playing well
enough that the jets should want to keep
that so
there's a very small sweet spot there
where he would play so well that someone
else would say we'll take the balance of
the contract and give you something for
him and the jets would say please take
him we don't want this bum around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports